so I just finished watching the show yet
last night so I'm gonna buff it right
now like what was the experience like
for you seeing the show like watching it
back um watch me back was kind of hard
because I wasn't able to watch it with
Harry cuz we're not quarantined in the
same country so it was hard not to like
hug him during the hard parts or like
cuddle him during the cute parts but I
mean there was some stuff that happened
that I was a little bit shocked about so
it was hard like that but I think
everything that was gonna happen I was
like prepared because I lived it so I
was like prepared for the shower scene
and I was prepared for the dates and
stuff like that so I had like a year to
like just mentally like I'll get ready
for what was it right yeah let something
like seeing you know everyone else's
perspective like they're doing the
confessionals and that kind of thing was
there anyone who surprised you or did
anything surprise you like seeing it
back and seeing everyone's perspective I
think that it was more positive than I
was expecting like I was expecting there
to be a lot of confessionals that were
just like purely like hating on me but
there wasn't I don't know if Netflix
just didn't want to show that or how
that went down but of course like there
are some things that were said that I
was like oh like that's kind of whatever
but I was also you know saying some
things so right like is there what is
there one person who your opinion of
them has changed after sting the show um
no I don't think so like living in it it
was a lot harder for me to live in live
it than it was for me to watch back
because watching it back I didn't see as
much hate as I was receiving when I was
living it so it was like easier to watch
in that sort of sense yeah because I saw
the one article in the one interview
that you did like they called you the
villain of the show like is that weird
to get that label um so I I have been
prepared that that was gonna be my label
like I knew I lost the most money I went
on the most dates like I did I made some
controversial decisions
like that so I was prepared that to be
the villain but production kept
reassuring me like okay like you don't
have anything to worry about like we're
not gonna paint anyone in a really bad
light so I was like okay like I was
nervous but I mean there are people
calling me like the villain but the love
that I've been receiving on my social
media and stuff like that has been like
the most overwhelming because I mean I
avoid Twitter and I avoid Facebook
because I look at that and I'm like oh
my god I think it's so bad but it makes
sense like I had sex on TV I you know
did other things that are very
controversial to you know the normal
person so no the one episode you say I
don't regret doing it but I regret
getting caught
yeah do you have do you have any regrets
like watching a backer I mean though a
kiss with Haley was my one of my
favorite moments it was it was like such
like a fun few days for us when before
it was revealed that it was us like we
were running around like little minions
like it was a lot of fun but the the
thing I would probably say I would
regret would be like the shower scene
with cows that didn't necessarily need
to happen and I was a little bit flirty
on the date with Corey but as you saw
there was a bottle of patron there so
dirty and like maybe one seen with Harry
when I was like I went down and everyone
was saying so I mean I'm almost like I
messaged her I was like oh hey like how
are you like honestly I'm really proud
of you even though you give a TV it's
like yeah I didn't it would be yeah like
you said so you filmed us a year ago so
you and Harry basically about the likes
each other in secret right all that time
yeah and then of course now yeah now
you're quarantined separately so how you
guys maintaining this one because when
was last time you saw the last time I
saw him was right before quarantine
happened so it was very end of February
beginning of March and then home to
visit my family and Ontario and while I
was in Ontario all of this stuff
happened so I was like okay like I can't
go to see you you can't come to see me
like we were looking it up all day
yesterday like is the travel ban legit
can
I go to the states but from what Google
is telling us it is legit so we just
remind each other like this is gonna be
over soon isn't gonna last forever like
our relationship has been such a test
from the beginning so as long as we can
get through these next few weeks or next
like hopefully not few months then I
think we'll be solid right I know you
guys talking about possibly getting
married in order to get over the border
yeah because I was looking it up and you
can come to Canada if your spouse is
here so I was like like we were already
talking about getting engaged and like
looking at rings so I was like listen if
this at the end of the month on the 21st
if they announced the travel bans
continuing for another month like we
have to do something about it you know I
mean like I won't marry you you want to
marry me of course we'll celebrate it
later but like if that's what we got to
do like 100% right and you guys got like
matching tattoos right yeah we have
lightning bolts on our fingers awesome
what's that why'd you choose the
lightning bolt um it kind of just
symbolized our entire journey cuz as you
saw like there was a lot of negativity
surrounding everything we were doing in
the house like every time we lost money
and stuff like that so it just kind of
reminded us to like stay positive and
not focus on the negative and also when
I was drawing like the cat the cat and
the Oni challenge I put lightning bolts
all over except reminded me of Harry so
it's just kind of a dictation everything
he met your family right
yeah what do they think of him my
parents were very supportive I think
they they think they raised me properly
so they respect my judgment of course
they were like oh he's a little young
and my sister was like very skeptical
because my sister is more protective
over me than anyone so she was like he's
like a year older than me I was like
yeah but like age doesn't really matter
like you know what I mean but it's hard
in that kind of sense but other than
that they've been very supportive look
like why do you think you and Harry work
I just think he's not like anyone I've
ever dated and obviously my dating
history hasn't worked out for a reason
so he's just very goofy and we bring out
like a weird side of each other and
we're just like compatible on another
like on so many levels it just like fits
together it's like it looks
but he's just like everything I need
that I didn't know that I needed until I
met him is there anyone else in the show
you keep in touch with Haley Haley just
Haley right now just Haley yeah yeah
it's like you guys like a group group
text or anything that you guys do or
yeah there's a group chat um called Lana
is BAE and that I know so everyone was
in that and then I left the group chat
last summer because the hate continued
off there it's all really well yeah I
really need this negativity so I left
and then I reacted myself I got one of
the cast members to riad me back in
before the show launched cuz I wanted to
like you know be friends with everyone
again but after the show comes out
there's I mean it wasn't really a shock
for me to see anything but I feel like
maybe it was a shock for them to see
some things that were going down and my
motive behind my actions and stuff so we
haven't really remained as close as I
would like but I mean we're connected to
like for life no matter what because we
expect this thing together yes and I
felt like you just passed three million
followers on Instagram which is awesome
but like what do you want to do next
like now you had this Fame like what are
you thinking you want to do well I had
my my label that I just started and I
think I want to like bring a lot more
aware awareness to like my vegan
lifestyle and stuff like that and
helping the environment I want to focus
on that like that's my next move but of
course like thinking of just the present
my goal right now is to just figure out
what the situation with Harry is gonna
be and how we're gonna see for the next
like that's my like immediate plan right
that was just figured look yeah we were
so much fun to watch yeah that's great
to get a chance to talk myself and not
think about the cameras and just like
not let anyone stop me from doing
anything cuz I was just like I don't
care if I'm gonna regret this like this
is what I want to do like yeah there's
cameras but you know yeah that's awesome
well I'm glad to see you're doing well
thanks much for taking some time to talk
with Jessica
you